joining me now is Virginia attorney
general Jason miaris now as I mentioned
in the angle Mr attorney general you
announced today that you're
investigating a story we've been in
front of which is Thomas Jefferson High
School in Fairfax County Virginia it's
now it's a school known for the talented
and gifted students they're
intentionally withholding knowledge of
National Merit Scholarship awards from
the students who receive them who needed
the information to use on their college
applications I guess all in the name of
equity what are we learning
well listen thank you so much for having
me I mean the the first public reports
of this were candidly shocking uh this
is particularly resonant for me as a as
the only person ever elected as a child
of an immigrant as attorney general I
know for the Immigrant story so many
education is the doorway to American
success and Thomas Jefferson High School
is considered one of the best high
schools in the entire country and its
majority minority but as we saw not just
with the National Merit but also so many
concerned parents in the Asian American
Community felt like their children were
losing their dreams and aspirations and
that's what's so heartbreaking is that
so many that come here that are that are
immigrants their children are living
dreams that were denied them and so
education is the pathway to the American
dream and so we're actually conducting
investigation in two area two areas
where the National Merit recognition
denied any of these students based on
their race or ethnic background and then
the admissions policy at Thomas
Jefferson High schools change quite
recently and we saw a huge drop in
enrollment in Asian American students
and his one mom told me listen my
daughter has done everything right since
the first grade and I'm having to sit
down with her and tell her you may lose
your dream of attending Thomas Jefferson
High School not because of anything
you've done but simply what your
background is the fact that you're
korean-american that should outrage
every American that's why we're
conducting a Virginia human rights
investigation that's our
anti-discrimination statue in Virginia
and and we're tackling to get to the
answers of what happened it looks like
the offers to Asian students this is
according to the Washington Post today
dropped from the typical 70 percent
to 55 that's just in one year
that's weird yeah it was I mean what's
happening yeah well I think what you're
seeing nationally you're seeing this all
over the country it seems like the only
state sanctioned form of bigotry in
America today is anti-asian bigotry and
and I feel like a lot of Asian Americans
are similar where Jewish Americans were
100 years ago in the 1920s and 30s when
you had Elite institution Elite places
of Higher Learning in schools that were
capping and denying admission the Jewish
American students simply because of
their ethnic background it was wrong a
hundred years ago Laura it's wrong now
and so that's what we have the office of
civil rights in in my attorney general's
office because we're going to root out
that discrimination and that's our goal
here is to get to these answers this is
awesome uh Mr attorney general I'm so
glad you're doing this and by the way of
course they're going to say a lot of
this is because of equity concerns
that's the new lingo they're using and
we're learning also that the the
principal at this school
is paying a contractor
631 thousand dollars for quote Equity
training that includes a controversial
Equity centered strategic plan with a
goal that equal outcomes for every
student take place without exception
now this this is a school for gifted
students I probably wouldn't have been
able to get in there Jason so but
they're paying over a half million
dollars to learn about equal outcomes
for all students what does how does that
compute at all
well Laura Equity without Excellence is
emptiness and that's part of the reason
why we're conducting this investigation
anybody that's part of my team whether
it's investigating Loudoun County the
parole board or this we ask them to be
Fearless we ask them to be deliberate
and so we are going to go ahead we're
going to be hopefully they will
cooperate with us but if not we have
subpoena Powers we're going to do that
deliberate review of what exactly is
happening is to get to the right answers
you have to be willing to ask the tough
questions we're going to be asking those
tough questions and getting answers for
the Commonwealth of Virginia on this
well if you get ahead of this Equity
Nightmare and expose it for what it is
because it sounds great right when you
hear oh Equity who's not in favor of
equity but it means discrimination and
I'm so glad you're on this I hope other
Attorneys General follow suit Mr
attorney general thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else